at seven p.m. eastern on America and the
courts on c-span Washington journal
continues at the table Greg Palast
author of the best democracy money can
buy thank you for joining us hey Paul
glad to be back with you yeah it's been
about a year and you ever the a revised
American edition of your book which we
can see here the best democracy money
can buy what's in this new edition that
you can tell just the new expanded
election edition you gotta look for the
right third expand election edition
which if this last elections which pick
it up it's going to be collectors items
so there's couple new things with about
the last book had ten chapters ten
different stories I report for BBC
television and it's kind of the stories
that you're not allowed to see on
American TV except the I got a
Washington journal and it included the
last time we had a had the story about
how five months before the election Jeb
Bush and Katherine Harris purged tens of
thousands of voters off the voter rolls
they said that they were criminals you
know people who can't vote in Florida
because they're ex-cons and I just want
to show you this because some people are
always doubting what I'm talking about I
got this out of the computer files of
Katherine Harris I don't know if you can
catch it that up on the ladder just easy
these are the criminals who can't vote
in Florida including this guy here
there's a thomas cooper and you could
see that he was convicted on the
thirtieth of january 2007 so you know
katherine harris is out there finding
the criminals of the future there were
thousands on her list and that's by the
way with the side of the election could
also see on there something else that he
was black we're not guessing most of the
people on of the 94,000 targeted were
african-americans that was you know
election decided by 537 votes now that's
just the beginning of the story though
the purge is back it's back in the new
elections addition purges back big time
you write that in the nation as well
vanishing votes yeah the nation has an
excerpt from the book out today and so
we're talking about the purge being run
across 50 states our president is just
you know and our Congress has given us
the healthy
Americans vote act they're going to help
us vote as soon as the Bush family says
they're going to help us code I do get a
little bit concerned and one of the
things that they're doing of course will
be computerizing the vote what's serious
about this is that no discussion has
really been no discussion that in fact
computerizing the vote is going to have
a huge racial impact on loss of vote so
you're going to disenfranchise a lot of
black voters this way and they've been
testing out I mean one of the great
hidden stories of America's democracy is
that in the last election according to
the u.s. Civil Rights Commission and
Chris edley Commissioner is also
studying this out of Harvard Law School
1.9 million votes were cast and never
counted so you have a huge non vote in
America just thrown away for technical
reasons they call them spoiled by the
way you don't spoil a vote by leaving it
out of the fridge it's like a technical
reason and I discovered when I was
investigating for BBC that it looked
like there was a distinct color to the
spoiled votes i went into the blackest
county in florida gadsden the highest
number of votes simply thrown out one in
eight votes that were cast are actually
just thrown in the garbage Gaza's the
blackest county why if you made a
mistake on the ballot by the way
mistakes met writing in Al Gore's name
because it didn't couldn't be read by
the machines right in Al Gore's name
your vote is thrown out Tallahassee Leon
County the whitest in Florida it cast
your vote you make a mistake the
machines are right there in the
precincts they give you new ballot black
county make a mistake ballots thrown out
white county make a mistake here's your
new ballot u.s Civil Rights Commission
investigated here's what they found
180,000 ballots were thrown in the
dumpster in florida in two thousand one
hundred and eighty thousand ballots
fifty four percent of those cast by
black voters and the bad news is that
this is typical of the 1.9 million votes
thrown out in america for supposedly
technical reasons about half are 1
million votes are cast by black
americans so you're talking about a huge
jim crow thumb on the
sales and and we're not addressing it
and and the computerization is going to
make that far worse our guests will be
with us for this full hour he is greg
palast investigative reporter and author
of the best democracy money can buy here
with the phone numbers to call we're
talking about the election a rack
anything else you want to talk about for
our guests if you support Democrats it's
202 5853 881 if your supporter of
President Bush it's 5853 880 and export
others 2025 853 882 will get to your
calls just a minute amplifying the story
about the election USA Today as this
piece survey one in five voters will use
electronic ballots the election
assistance Commission it's going to have
a hearing on electronic voting today and
there's this story as well it's in the
washington times and he says voter rolls
found badly mismanaged voter
registration is so widely mismanaged in
this country that election officials in
261 counties certified more voters than
the actual adult population during the
presidential race four years ago a lot
of inaccuracies they're saying here what
does all this mean okay look out the
remember i just told you I we had a 1
million vote blackout in the last
election 1 million black votes cast not
counted we're moving to computer
supposedly to solve the problem
Katherine Harris the Honorable who's up
the hill here now one of her last accent
office was to order and push for
computerization of the vote in Florida
this is going to be the great fix well
they tried it out in broward county in
the white precincts it looked pretty
good I mean we don't know what goes on
in those black boxes but in the white
priests it looked good in the black
precincts they couldn't find the
passwords machines were locked up polls
are closed most of the day all and
several precincts thousands of black
votes lost in broward county in 2002 the
white areas were fine in other words the
computers worked exactly as intended
this is the problem what's happened in
the United States what's happened the
United States is that we have been while
the 1965 Voting Rights Act gave black
people right to vote they didn't give
them the right to have their votes
counted as a practical matter this and
when we move to computerization we're
going to have the same old story we're
going to have a test of hardware and
software
involving millions of people with the
outcome being the presidency it will all
be tested on one day and watch right now
in the black districts black precincts
is going to be just like Broward County
Florida you're going to see not the
fancy stuff of the hacking into the
machines that's that that's going to
happen but that it's not the the hacking
in that you have to worry about its the
unplugging it's the rubbin your cat and
zapping out a black precinct that's
going to make the difference and that's
going to and that static electricity is
going to elect the next president the
United States well let's go to Florida
for our first call for Greg Palast
Jacksonville welcome to the program good
morning hi there how are you doing dude
well I'm so glad to see you on there
discussing this I'm from duval county
which the city is the county so it's the
largest city in the continental United
States and in the election it's a real
hotbed of Republican dead rock
conservatives in here they threw away
over 20 I don't know what the number is
but over 20,000 doubts were thrown away
on the black side of town because we had
this very confusing butterfly ballot
that I even found confusing i'm not
saying that it was it was it was just so
screw the way they had it set up it went
back and forth and back and forth and so
they decide we'll just throw all these
votes away and the fact that so many
people are disenfranchised here and it
just i don't think it was even hardly
mentioned in duval county because jim
king who's the head of the state senate
is from here a bush comes here all the
time this is a very you know this is
really his base here in florida and i'm
just don't worried about to convince the
the election i'm just i'm i'm worried to
death I really nothing to worry about
you you got it you've locked right into
it and you've got it exactly and what's
going on in what happened in Florida let
me repeat this one hundred and eighty
thousand votes we're not counting forget
what Jim Baker said about counting the
votes six times he accept don't look at
the dumpster with a hundred eighty
thousand votes thrown away is spoiled
okay don't look at those hundred eighty
thousand votes if you go precinct by
precinct match it to the demographics in
that area you will find that the
majority fifty-four percent according to
the commission of the votes thrown out
in Florida are black votes it's one
thing after another either they don't
put machine readers in the
back areas and by the way when they fix
the machines they order the fixed
machines out that's what's happened in
Gaza and they fixed the machines in the
black areas and and now they're going to
computerize it they're going to take
machines that work and pull them out so
yes you've locked right onto it and the
cameras the u.s. you know crews are out
in looking at the hanging chads and Palm
Beach you know why white folk and white
folk in bikinis more moreover who lost
their vote and in the black areas where
the real vote loss occurred there were
no cameras you're not going to see that
and it's going to be absolutely worse
like I said they tested out the new
machinery and broward black people
couldn't vote white people could the in
other words the computers work perfectly
we're going to see this in places like
Texas comal county had a very
interesting result with the new ivo
tronix machines you're talking three
candidates Republican candidates one
upset victories with 18,000 181 votes
each quite a coincidence according to
the Republican election supervisor
scurry county same thing where
Republicans want to upset but there they
had a verification method reran it and
golly the Democrats won how are they
solving that problem they're eliminating
verification hey listen do you get you
go to 7-eleven you get a receipt for a
Slurpee you vote for the president the
united states they don't give you
anything think about it summerville
south carolina for greg palast welcome
to the program hello hi hey yeah this is
uh Summerville South Carolina let me
know what y'all are very upset with
Terry's running for president there was
there was a hundred officers served with
him in Vietnam and 200 people there
signed that they knew Karen they knew
that he didn't get the purple heart that
he's very unfit for presidency till I
just hope people learn
turn well I think that you made a good
point here I think that you know look at
Kerry's war record vs Bush as you know
Bush defended this in Texas Air Guard
defended the skies of Houston from Viet
Cong attack they were so afraid of him
that they that they didn't even dream of
bombing Texas so obviously our
commander-in-chief currently really has
the war experience we need if you go
into the new addition to my book you'll
see more about our current president's
war record and how he got out of it even
more how the story of how the fix was
put in to get him out of Vietnam and
into the Air Guard has to do with a
keeping silent that little story and
that has a lot to do with the lobbyists
of Texas and and contracts let their
with us I won't go into that story until
Patriot Act three you're still allowed
three books stay with the administration
for a moment here here's a fax Greg I
enjoy your style of political commentary
please give your opinion of the Bush
administration's efforts to keep the
Cheney energy meeting papers out of the
public domain well now this is
interesting because when our vice
president says that these are national
security matters he may be right that
doesn't mean they should be kept secret
from us we do know from the good work of
judicial water republican-backed
organization that one things these
energy executives are going over besides
the energy you know basically lobbyists
fixing the energy policy of America
that's creepy enough but they have to be
going over a map of a certain
Mesopotamian nation black speckles all
over the map each one an oil field of
Iraq what were all executives and Dick
Cheney doing going over the oil maps of
Iraq six weeks after the inauguration
this is way before September 11th what
we doing looking at the oil maps of Iraq
and that meeting I do know by the way
that there were meetings and I've spoken
to the people in the meetings discussing
the post conquest plans for disposition
of the oil of Iraq so these are oil
companies that because we know that we
had shell in there we had conocophillips
in there discussing these these items
within you know almost before the the
tuxes were returned from the inaugural
they began very very early
so yeah I'm very concerned I think that
the point what they're trying to keep
out of the public domain is not that the
fix was put in by the oil companies to
set our energy policy I think that you
know you'd have to just fall off a
watermelon truck to believe it that
didn't happen I think they want to keep
out of out of our sight the fact that
they were discussing not only the oil
plans but the military plans because
energy policy under this administration
comes out of the barrel of a gun and
that's what we ought to know about call
it from Wheaton Maryland just outside DC
go ahead Wheaton good morning Greg it's
good to see on TV I'm looking forward to
seeing you may 12th at Dennis UDC for
your talk then good I'll be with the
n-double-a-cp and the Civil Rights
Commissioner Headley WPF w2 yep okay
question Wheatley yeah I was wondering
um what can Americans do to make sure
our votes count like is there anything
that we can do for this coming election
or for the future elections yea vote
early and often i mean the the elections
are not going to be decided by 51%
anymore you're gonna have to win by more
if you don't control the machines and by
the way let's let's not kid ourselves
this is a bipartisan Jim Crow effort the
worst spoilage in America occurs in
Florida black vote loss Georgia black
vote loss Chicago Illinois where a white
minority leadership of a black majority
Democratic Party stays in power by not
counting those black votes what we have
to do is we volunteers poll watcher keep
your eyes open complaint holler and
scream when the machines are locked up
and don't let them do it because public
pressure in California last week let the
decertification of the Diebold machines
you know these these fixable black boxes
which will now be thrown into the
Pacific but that's only that's not the
biggest company out there selling this
peddling these democracy gizmos so if we
scream enough I think will make a
difference today there are hearings on
the hill regarding computer voting
demand that receipt so that we can have
a paper count Canada Sweden other
nations have working democracies and
they do it by paper ballot read in
public that's called a democracy
the rest is the gates of vacation of our
vote is a little bit dangerous take us a
little bit deeper into this
investigative report you're doing for
the BBC as much as you can what else are
you working on well I'm working BBC and
Rolling Stone a lot of things that I was
able to get ahold of Word documents from
Paul from inside the administration I
know that the wall street journal did a
terrific job getting some of these to
these were the post I have a hundred
page document the post conquest plan or
post-conflict plan as they call it for
the economy of Iraq that's a pretty
dangerous stuff where we are already
dividing up the assets of Iraq it calls
for the sale of quote all state assets
including and it says especially in the
oil and supporting industries is that
why we were there that's a good question
then we now know that there was a
200-page addendum to that which was
written up by you know by those good
Patriots for us at various oil companies
and with help from the Council on
Foreign Relations I mean we should know
about these documents at this point so
we're working on that the other thing is
I just speaking the general Jay garner
here in Washington for the BBC we report
this on BBC television we couldn't get
it out in the United States general Jay
if you remember he was our first kind of
Pasha that we put in power there the
Viceroy but he's actually quite popular
in Iraq new Iraqis well he was yanked
out right away and why let's not forget
he jumps off a plane and calls for a
democracy elections within 90 days of
arriving in in the Mideast elections
within 90 days for rack Iraq for Iraqis
he said in more dangerously said Iraqi
oil for Iraqis he arrives in Baghdad
with his democracy plan gets a call from
Don Rumsfeld he tells me basically don't
unpack your out now he doesn't like to
say he's fired but everyone knows he was
not only fired out of the White House
comes rumors that he's hapless
incompetent unlikable I mean they did a
hit on this guy from inside the White
House like a KGB hit to ruin him why
because he was demanding democracy for
Iraqis turning the place over to the you
know giving them their country getting
us out out but that didn't go with the
play
hands for dividing up the oil fields
which you know which is right in the
program and that requires nearly a year
so the question is not why do we go in I
don't know why we went in you know we
can we could argue that back and forth
forever the question is why are we still
there and the answer you have to look
back into these documents for the
programs for taken over and chopping and
dicing Iraq's assets including the oil
fields and so are we there to bring them
democracy or prevent or to prevent
democracy moving on in knoxville
tennessee for greg palast hello
knoxville knoxville good morning what am
i up I had something else I was going to
talk about when you brought up the oil i
just read in the paper a couple of days
ago that the Americans again did not get
the bid for the oil supplies that they
went to two other countries and I don't
think your bid up on this we have not
gotten very much we're not the American
oil countries are not getting the
profits from this but my big thing I
called about was mrs. Harris and you're
saying about the felon lift each one of
those were mailed and each Democrat that
was in charge of every county or whoever
whatever counties they were supposed to
go through those roles and decide where
they are were they not and are they
eligible are they not and if they didn't
do that before the election that is not
mrs. Harris's fault and secondly when
you talk about wait wait wait before you
go onto secondly yeah actually let's get
our facts straight the NWACC p after i
ran my report after i ran my report and
the Washington Post ran it by about
seven months after after I did it for
the British news well I'll Corps was
still a race you have to understand the
n-double-a-cp sued the state and the
state did sign off that they did wrongly
remove thousands of voters from the
voter rolls most of them are black
people we're not guessing they're black
is right on these little lists inside
the computer we can't you can count them
up okay and in terms of oh well it's not
my fault yeah that's that's Harris's
line it ain't my fault ok and that's
Jeb's line and ain't my fault well I
also have internal documents i showed
you a guy convicted in the future you
know Thomas Cooper January how they get
somebody
wait there are 500 ml on this list there
are 500 criminals of the future I went
into their computers at the Harris's
office in the state and in the state
computers emails from clerks saying hey
we're disenfranchising people who are
convicted in the future what do we do
well the answers don't disenfranchised
and I thought instead the Republican
functionaries send notes saying well if
Yuri blank out the conviction dates no
one will know the supervisors won't know
this they're 4,000 blank conviction
dates they sent the supervisors list
with no hint that they knew darn well
these lists were bogus the company that
came up with a list choice point of
Atlanta they have provided app
uncontroverted the proof that they
provided memos statements to the state
saying this is not a list of felons
there are no 94,000 people who have
illegally registered if they had
illegally registered the Attorney
General there told me he would arrest
them he put them in jail there are six
cases not ninety four thousand cases
let's get the facts straight this was a
Jim Crow operation they knew it call her
anything else yes I would like to say
also in each of the counties that they
had their major voting problems of
Democrats stem cells were in charge of
those counties if they didn't teach
those voters how to vote how to use the
machines or how to punch the little
Chad's and do all that that's their
fault they said and they did not do it
okay so let me see wait wait just a
second let's both stop it and I think
the president won that election by more
than five hundred and eighty-five
thousand are a 585 votes that's when
they stopped the county they didn't even
bother counting the rest of this I know
oh yes that's right they did this key
okay now okay military those words never
cat thanks call all right let me just
get an answer all right there were uh
you say that the bush won by only 580 is
seven votes he would have won by more
fair to counted it was George Bush who
sued to stop the count coz theta counted
those hundred eighty thousand votes and
dumpster mostly black folks how exactly
how many votes you think you would have
worn by demographically we would
estimate about the 80 some thousand
votes that would have been al gore state
by 80 some thousand votes
back and now you're also making the
point about whose fault is it that
people can't handle the ballots and you
know what this is it's the old line that
black people are too dumb to figure out
the ballots let's be straight about this
line here it's the old racist line black
people can't figure out the ballot i
have to tell you the u.s Civil Rights
Commission investigated that they said
look maybe that's true we have to look
at it coldly in fact you take the worst
case of ballots being thrown out in the
blackest County in Florida gadsden they
had if you made a mistake on a ballot
your ballot was thrown out the same
exact ballot was used in Tallahassee and
in Tallahassee they had machine readers
right in the precinct they stuck your
ballot right in the machine if you made
a mistake you got a new ballot it had
nothing to do with whether you are smart
or dumb when they change the machines in
gadsden in the 2002 election almost no
votes were lost at all it's not that
black people got smarter and white
people got Dumber they white people and
black people have the same ballots in
the same machines the same number votes
are lost so let's not use the racists
line that black people are too dumb to
vote our guest is greg palast author of
the best democracy money can buy here's
a look at the book the expanded election
edition it's bad gonna let you see you
at you're missing a chapter there you go
you brought it with you thank you for
presenting that to us also an
investigative reporter of course tell us
more about your work you mentioned you
can't get your stuff published or aired
here in this country how does all that
work or not work in your view well you
know what we have a it's kind of like an
electronic Berlin Wall I mean I did the
story of the loss the disenfranchisement
of black voters in which Jeb Bush and
katherine harris and her predecessor
wiped out thousands of black voters I
ran that story within three weeks of the
election Al Gore was in the raced he
hadn't shaved they hadn't grown a beard
yet and it was not picked up it was
picked up by The Washington Post thank
you guys seven months later in june
where mr. bush could read it from the
oval office and giggle it was finally
mentioned by the new york times of
out three months ago when they said it
should never happen again they didn't
run the story in the first place of
black out of the vote okay the why can't
you get these stories it that's a very
good question I ran the story about
about mr. garner general garner calling
for elections that getting him in hot
water about the the plans to divide up
the the oil assets of Iraq this ran on
BBC nightly news at the top of the news
the only place i saw that mention united
states is paul krugman mentioned BBC
News reported I ran the story of working
with national security news service here
the great team headed by Joe trento
coming right out of here we had
documents from FBI agents showing that
they could not they could not
investigate the US members of the bin
Laden family until September 13 2001
front-page news all over the world top
of the nightly news BBC page 0 here con
labs remember that story our president
was shocked that that there's a flea
market in fishin being run by the
Pakistanis by this you know dr.
Strangelove dr. Khan right we ran and he
was shocked by this BBC Nightly News and
The Guardian and I got a California
State University Journalism Award for
this we ran a story two years ago saying
that not only was con running a flea
market and fishing but that the Bush
administration had blocked
investigations of con labs because the
money the funding for this little
operation went back to Saudi Arabia so
now we had the post and we had the New
York Times saying our president shocked
about this news about Pakistan nuclear
bomb he's not shocked he ordered he the
reason you didn't know is he ordered the
investigator i should say his national
security agencies block the
investigation warren michigan good
morning good morning mr. palace i read
your first book loved it and i think
you're a godsend to democracy but let me
tell you i majored in history political
science and law degree in george
washington and i'm so frustrated what
ken citizens do to stop all this it goes
on how can we reclaim our democracy you
know it when you're fighting judges now
that are appointed by Bush when you're
you know you've got the Harrises and
what have you how can you fight this so
that we can return democracy to the
people well okay I think it's a good
point what do we do last thing I want
people do is be frustrating oh they're
going to knock counter vote because it's
going to be electronically zapped or
they're not listening to us I think what
we have to do is tell the truth on them
get to the get to the sources i mean i
peer on the BBC nightly news you can get
it on the internet go to my website greg
palast calm click right through and get
the television that's too dangerous to
show in America get the word out you
know I mean if what you want to do in
this in this life is watch Scarborough
Riley factory I have no problem with
that but that's you know that's news
attainment go to the BBC go The Guardian
go to other sources to to get some hard
harder news i mean it's simple things I
don't want to by the way say that I'm
some grand investigative report I just
have good editors that let me do the
stories I got you know I here on the I
did day at training with Fox News people
and he's told me a news report is to
sound bites 40 seconds of narration and
stand up to camera 90 seconds that's
your news story they said what you know
what do you think and i said i think i'm
leaving the country i do 14 minutes for
a news story and on the nightly news in
britain so i can tell you the story it's
expensive it's difficult and i have a
great sympathy for the reporters here
who don't have the freedom to do the
work spend the money and get the good
story we go now to Clayton North
Carolina good morning to you yes good
morning Greg it is a distinct honor to
speak to you one of the things that I do
to try to spread the Democratic feeling
is to give your book to my friends and
have them earmark pages and highlight it
and wonderful source of information I
give you kudos I think that the best
exemplary thing that shows that there is
basically at this Berlin Wall that
you're speaking about it every time that
the elections of 2000 or spoken
it's all about the hanging chads that's
the only thing that you hear about you
never hear anything about the voter
rolls which which used soap so well put
out there and it wasn't reported my real
question to you is this I would like for
you to discuss the importance of the new
emerging independent media that we have
your you're a guest on face off the
Canadian show of democracy now and Amy
Goodman and Juan Gonzalez is marvelous
work if you could comment on that and
most most specifically the the man in
the chicken suit as you say Michael
Michael Laurel yeah I I thank you very
much by the way the check will be in the
mail Clayton let me mention Michael
Moore because of course he wrote your
book is quote courageous reporting but
he has a new movie out yes and here's
the story in The New York Times Disney
is blocking distribution of film that
criticizes Bush disease blocking its
miramax division from distributing this
new documentary by mr. Morra that
harshly criticizes mr. bush the film was
called fahrenheit 911 links mr. Bush and
prominent Saudis including the family of
bin Laden and criticizes mr. Bush's
actions before and after the September
11 terrorist attacks well obviously Paul
I take this personally because those
people realize that a lot of Michael
Moore's filming and writing is based on
my investigative reporting so there's a
lot from my book basically it's the film
is partly taken from my book I don't
know the final the final script but this
is one of the problems there is no
discussion there is no discussion these
reports of the blocking of the
investigations of Khan labs of the
investigation of the Saudi connection to
the Bush family let's have a discussion
I think I think it in fact is kind of
sad that my reports which you can see on
the top of the nightly news all over the
planet except America to get them into
America I got to sneak him in and you
know give them to the fat guy in the
chicken suit so he can make a joke on
them it's the only way I can get in
these reports use the first one to bring
over my reports of the of the purge of
the vote in Florida way before the The
Washington Post the picked it up so yeah
obviously censorship ain't pretty
whether it's in Fallujah or Hollywood or
anywhere else they tried it before with
his book stupid white men they
kept me out the best democracy money can
buy by the way was printed in England
not in the United States until it became
a Best New York Times bestseller despite
the being having to be lobbed across the
water so there's no political discussion
will allow you know kind of the
fruitcake factor you know Ann Coulter
and calling everyone traders that's
allowed all over our press but Michael
Moore bring up some uncomfortable
information Greg pals bring up the
uncomfortable information lemoore it
can't be done yeah little more from that
piece mr. Moore's agent according to
this new york times p zarry Emanuel said
mr. Eisner Disney's chief executive
asked him last spring to pull out of the
deal with miramax mr. Emanuel said mr.
Eisner expressed particular concern that
would endanger tax breaks Disney
receives for its theme park hotels and
other ventures in Florida where mr.
Bush's brother Jeb as governor okay
confession i mean Michael and I have the
same agent Ari and but look the problem
is no discussion I'm not going to vouch
for every word in someone else's film
and that's the problem I mean I KY not
the greg palast filming his own films
here why do we why can't we get these
the hard-edged reporting in as I do for
BBC I'd like to see that discussion in
the American press I would like why is
it that the rest of the world gets to
see general J garner discuss the secret
plans for the division of Iraq's assets
the scuppered plans for elections there
that would be saving our boys lives
right now why did everyone else in the
planet get to see this report why wasn't
it run on us television this is the big
issue why the blank out why the black
out and you tell me i mean i'd like to
know because my kids are getting these
like weird little british Upstairs
Downstairs accents i moved back to the
US whether they like it or not mount
gilead ohio for greg palast thanks for
waiting hi good morning mr. Ellison i
understand i think the flushing of the
people from the voter rolls i think i
got that under my Ken and I understand
how under boats that is where know where
the machine didn't count any vote for
president how you could look at it and
see yes there is a hole or yes there's a
swinging jet and that should be counted
if you're saying
you know the intent of the motor but I
don't understand how the over votes
occur and how you might look at a ballot
and see that that the overboard should
be counted one way or the other could
you explain the different circumstances
where those over votes occurred okay let
me bring up something that's kind of
technical and fancy bow put it in kind
of human language an over vote for
example in gadsden people check Al
Gore's name then they wrote in Al Gore
consider I tin candidates name not right
night not right hyphen in candidates
name so you actually had two votes both
for Al Gore all right that's an over
vote that was thrown out if you were
black let me repeat that it was all
thrown out if you were in the black
County if you were in the White County
and checked George Bush and wrote George
Bush they said you over voted you get
another ballot they stick in the machine
it would come back you got another
ballot so the issue is not whether votes
were thrown out because if it was
completely random then it really
wouldn't matter statistically you'd say
well it could be anyone's life but it's
not anyone's vote black areas the votes
were lost white areas the votes were
saved and here's the bad word from the
u.s Civil Rights Commission statistician
Florida is typical but that's not good
but the but the apparently on the punch
card machines also there were over boat
which when you looked at the ballot
wasn't weren't over votes at all you
know when that when the Compendium
counted the votes the newspaper people
they found a parent / votes which worked
over votes it on that's what I don't
understand yeah the consortium axes they
call themselves the big papers it was
actually done by the University of
Chicago went through the ballots in
Florida and in and I they didn't really
report those results because it remember
the results were coming out around
September 11th just after the attack and
they and basically they fudged the
results go to the University of Chicago
website the National Opinion Research
Center what you'll see is that if you
went by what people thought they were
doing
they're casting the ballots the exit
polls are correct most people thought
most people thought that they were
voting for Al Gore now look I'm not a
big fan of how gorgeous so you
understand just that he happened to have
won the election here's another email on
the same issue do we want instant
results or do we want accurate results
should we go to 100% paper ballots or
paper ballots safer from tampering by
local election officials to receipts
protect our right to secret ballots okay
a couple things paper ballots I've
talked to the experts around the planet
the cleanest elections on this planet
whether it's England Sweden Canada are
done by paper which are read first by
machines and the Machine can't read the
vote you all read it all parties all
members of public read the ballot in
public okay simple and as they had in
the white counties in Florida you stick
the ballot in the in a reader and if it
doesn't read properly you get another
ballot and you correct it so you're not
going to have any mistakes you're going
to have we're talking about massive
massive chaos in November massive
imagine testing all this software and
hardware on a single day with millions
of people test on a single day with a
help heck of an outcome this isn't AOL
9.2 this is this is who's you know
running the free world that's the we are
heading it to what well I won't call it
a disaster because one man's disasters
another man's inauguration those guys
out there that guy in the White House
well as the people who think for him
know exactly what will happen on
Election Day chaos and the black
precincts that's what's that's what
we're heading to we lost a million black
votes in the year 2000 we're going to
lose more than that in 2004 Oakland
California for Greg Palast good morning
yeah hi there hey listen um I remember
during to Florida 2000 that a black
sailor called c-span and he was on shore
leave at the time and he claimed that
that on his ship over eleven hundred
votes from black sailors were thrown out
and whether I guess he was made it would
be interesting to have him either
contact c-span or contact you to give
you a little bit more information on
that by the way I need to deputize all
the viewers here you brought up a good
point
I do investigative reporting which i
think is illegal Paul under Patriot Act
three or something but it's I need help
so go to Greg go to triple w greg palast
calm jerry g PA la stss contact greg if
you have a source if you have
information you have documents that
someone thought you want to shred but
you think I to take a look at don't
hesitate to send me a note that's how I
get my info I do need some help I can't
report on that particular story as an
investigative reporter i think is
dangerous for me to report or comment on
a story that i haven't investigated
that's a big big mistake don't you know
that for those who think that i'm here
to go get mr. bush if we end up with a
president carry i have a feeling that
he's going to be just about as unhappy
as mr. bush's with me Fort Lewis
Washington good morning good morning mr.
pals they pronounce your last Halas yes
yeah it's a it's a pleasure and honor to
speak with you as a matter of fact I'm
retiring from the Army up here at Fort
Lewis and once I got your name and your
email address I ran out in my underwear
to my band to get a pin so i can write
it down the reason I'm calling sir is a
thank you don't get arrested oh no no I
can just see it Palace fans and
underwear go ahead anyway sir the reason
I'm calling yes I agree with you a
hundred percent the discrepancies that
took place in the two thousand election
should be talked about but the thing
that disturbs me even more and I wish
that you and other investigative
reporters would focus on this because
apparently it's been forgotten in the
media that is when weapons of mass
destruction were used against Americans
ie the anthrax attacks we furs nothing
about this there's been nobody that's
been brought to justice there's not even
any suspects and I wish somebody would
do an investigation and find out who is
responsible for this because apparently
we still hear politicians trying to make
the connection to the Saddam Hussein
regime and the Taliban which is
absolutely ridiculous well look here's
my one I don't know the story well
enough I you'll have to like get to my
website Greg Palast com send the
material to me I'll have to evaluate it
i just don't know i have to really look
into these investigations are really
expensive it's one of the reasons why
they're not done on commercial
television it's very difficult to get
these these things out because it's just
a lot of big expensive investigating
another Floridian vero beach good
morning yeah my name is Ray um Ivan I
are two recently and got involved but
the first thing was this this election
debacle in two thousand but these
especially focused on this who fought
one up you risk of people that request
one on the correct this problem I saw an
article of paper down here the other day
that somebody suggested why not apply
for absentee ballots that way you be
sure be counted and done in printing I'd
like to have your phone on that and then
tell me what is done is the meal bushes
and the other for this appeal bushes the
history uh when he moves the world of
finance into the world of computers and
you discussed that and what companies he
was affiliated with thank you okay well
first of all we'll absentee ballots get
your vote counted mm-hmm not if for
example if you go by the katherine
harris rule in florida which is there's
a mistaken on the ballot if a machine
can't read it it ain't gonna count so
you make a mistake on that absentee
ballot you're not going to get another
one I think we have to go in and and
fight the fight all the way for
verifiable ballot so don't get thrown
out they can throw out your absentee
bout two in the same exact manner if
they are using machine readers save me
distrae mark so that's not gonna that's
not going to solve our democracy issues
as to Neil Bush yeah there's some real
questions about some of the friends he's
he's lining up to cash in and the war on
terror I mean that's one thing we have
to look at also in the new edition of my
book out this week is a whole new
section called fear for sale those guys
that came up with that cute little felon
list choice point they got out of the
election fixing business there
now into their now big contracts to
warrant air there's nice big fat no bid
contracts for your homeland security
which aren't you know it's the which by
the way in terms of making us more
secure and it's like the new duck and
cover you know don't look at the flash
what they're doing is they're coming up
with all kinds of these gimmicks the
choice point for example supply to our
government with voter lists of Venezuela
Brazil Mexico Argentina now what were
they doing in those countries I don't
remember any hijackers doing the tango
they're all from Saudi Arabia and from
the Arabian Peninsula we don't get those
records instead we're building files on
the Four Nations which happened to
either have or about to lect leftist
leaders who are not exactly friends of
George Bush so is our process now in the
war on terror to protect democracy or is
it oh is it a war on terror or is it a
war on democracy Neal bush in the bush
family Marvin bush and others seem to be
also making a few bucks off the the good
fear for sale game in addition to these
calls you've sparked a lot of folks to
write in about Florida is another fax
when you did the Voting analysis in
Florida what did you use as a control
did you also exam the Clinton election
in Florida I ask this because that the
same problems happen when Clinton was
elected it seems like it makes it it
makes it seem less like a bush
Republican conspiracy okay I'm sorry it
was a it was done it was a Republican
job and again as I told you in Chicago
it's a democratic job so it's it's not
one party doing this little game okay
but in Florida it's it's the Republican
game in particular there was in this did
not happen when bill clinton was running
for president the purges began in
nineteen ninety eight under Katherine
Harris's predecessor in response to a
so-called reform law just like our
little helping Americans vote act that
our president sign which is our supposed
reform which is a cover for more
mischief in 98 Florida had a voting
Reform Act which again was a cover for
mischief and that's when they instituted
the computerization of voter rolls which
is now happening nationwide and they
instituted the purges and so it was
new and unique to Florida but it's now
going nationwide and it was completely
under the control of Republican
functionaries it's a very bad idea to
put control of the election rolls in the
hands of secretaries of state it's not
just Katherine Harris their 50 Katherine
Harris's these are highly partisan
offices better to keep them where we've
had them for years at the county level
with bipartisan committees so you know
it is in fact and indeed in Florida it
was Republican fix in Illinois and
Chicago it's a democratic fix you take
your choice but either way you look at
it it ain't anything we call democracy
we go to brevard county florida for greg
palast good morning to you good morning
I have three things I want to say if I
could be first on Katherine Harris she
was rewarded by her white district and
it's now a representative from that
district in the US Congress she says she
sleeps well at night and the other thing
I wanted to say his and this is
unfortunate really badly about this but
deep in my heart if George Bush wins
again I will always have a mistrust that
this vote in Florida was not done fairly
I wish I could get that away but he has
placed such a mistrust he and his
brother and Katherine in us that we feel
we cannot trust the vote to be fair I
don't well what's what's the problem now
that we have computers you know you may
have already voted this year they just
haven't told you how you know I mean so
yeah I know we can't trust the current
system we couldn't trust the last system
like I said 1.9 million votes in the
United States were tossed in the garbage
and they had a distinctly black cast to
them so you cannot trust our elections
at this moment we've got to get rid of
this Jim Crow element in in voting in
America it's got to end and it's
something which is not discussed openly
in America it's hidden away see if you
can try this part of this fax why didn't
Al Gore stand up for a total recount of
Florida's votes why didn't Al Gore or
stand up people are always asking with
Democrats don't stand up it's like why
do I
the jellyfish stand up there in
vertebrates Washington DC for Greg
Palast hello am I on yes you are sir
okay my question is regarding the over
boats down there in the Democratic
counties versus the Republican counties
in Maryland we have a democratic
operative and Republican opportunity
there it's polling station to make sure
that they're checking on each other that
there's no improprieties existing what
happened in these Democratic counties
were the wasn't there a democratic
representative there and the Republican
counties to make sure things were
happened were executed equally well see
first of all no one knew about the
purges so you couldn't go in a vote if
you aren't registered people couldn't
figure out how to challenge I mean and
you did not have the type of poll
watching coverage that is that is
definitely needed when people ask what
can you do a simple practical thing say
I'm going to donate my day to democracy
I'm going to be poll watcher that will
help if there's any question about
whether someone's voting they now have a
right to provisional ballots say I want
to vote anyway give me that provisional
ballot yeah you can have people standing
around what what do you look at when
you're looking at at a computer voting
operation and you have poll Watchers
exactly what are they watching how do
they know what's going on behind that
panel and when by the way you had poll
Watchers in broward county in Florida
when those black machines went down when
the computers went down to black
precincts exactly what it's are the poll
watch is supposed to do and that's
what's going to happen in 2004 election
it will have no fingerprints it's just
going to be jam ups on machines votes
locked up inexplicable counts don't the
hacking is the least of the problem and
when I speaking to former now dean of
the law school at Berkeley Chris edly
who's saying you got to say something
about this people have got to know that
that the vote is in danger Atlantic
Beach Florida good morning to you hi
Donna calling I just wanted to ask the
gentlemen if you'll remember correctly
on the two thousand election uh Vice
President Gore okay from the state of
Tennessee did not even win his own state
wait just one second I don't
treat and win his own state because they
were purges going on in Tennessee we
really don't know the vote given the
massive amount of black boats thrown out
getting the purges we don't know if Al
Gore lost Tennessee mean that the vote
count went against him that's quite
different than saying he lost the state
let's be clear about that excuse me it's
a democratic state okay when they ran
the first time he and President Clinton
won the state okay so I don't tell me
then it was a virgin shall we say in
1996 when they ran the first time is
that what you're going to tell me are
you now going to tell me former
President Bush should have won the state
and he did not I don't know about the
vote counted to Tennessee but I do know
that in fact that choice point the
company that did the black bag job of
cleaning out the voter rolls in Florida
also it offered there its subsidiary dbt
it offered free purges in Tennessee
which was known to be a swing state so
we don't know exactly what happened in
Tennessee it's still an open question
this is one of the problems why should
we have questions at all about our
democracy and by the way I'm not here to
flak for Al Gore I don't that the
question is I'm here for the voters who
get disenfranchised mainly black voters
and that's that's the great crime here
that that isn't being discussed I hope
some of that by the way has a question
other than about the elections i right
about you know the world bank to Iraq to
oil companies to the Saudi connection
whatever you want but I'm happy to
answer your voting questions but maybe
someone has another question let's see
what's up in Cincinnati hello there I
apologize my question is of voting well
that's all right go right ahead this
one's on me I do read you on truthout
org it's a website that's been
absolutely imperative getting the truth
to someone like me here in Cincinnati
but my question is we work on things
locally here very small numbers compared
to the national picture but we got beat
on a levy a tax levy we're walk-in
voters came
they made a special trip to the polls to
vote to tax themselves we sent a citizen
down through the work day for the
recount we had talked to the board of
elections and a person sitting at their
deaths that they had ballots on their
desk we raised issues with this we lost
by four votes and I just wonder if in
the National picture walkins a play a
role I don't know that your particular
election what what Florida exposed and
what I'm now finding and you'll see in
the new additional book is that we
really have some dangers to the vote in
our democracy we always assume we went
in and we voted and they counted them up
what your findings at it's a it's a much
more if he process than that now I don't
know about your vote stacked up I do
know this in Florida and in other states
Jesse Jackson registered literally
hundreds of thousands of people through
what are called motor voter forms and in
Florida some of those forms just sat on
the floor the people signed the forms
they weren't entered into the voting
rolls they never got their confirmation
that they were voting and this happened
all over the country and again the motor
voter law those registration forms used
for motor voters they're called those
are primarily minority voters so we've
got a big problem people register who
aren't on the rolls people thrown off
illegally pleat people block for voting
machines don't work what we're finding
is that our democracy is much more of a
crapshoot than a than an accounting
process take us from Florida to
California Chapter three of your book
California Riemann deregulation of the
power pirates yeah the new new edition
California Riemann the story of power
pirates actually for those I've also
besides my bestseller written a worst
seller called democracy and regulation
my academic book on utility regulation
of all things don't read it it will put
you sleep but I should say that my
publisher will be really man but you
have the the easier version in the best
democracy money to buy the point here is
that we had a not only in California but
all over this country we've had a real
con going we've had a real con going
with this thing called deregulation
basically it's turning over democracy
the Democratic regulation Paul from from
controlled by regulators which are
chosen democratically to control by
little groups of executive sitting in
hotel rooms figuring out what the price
should be in California were in Nevada
or in Utah and so and the cons
continuing one thing I should mention
I'd story I just again I broke out in in
England but not here is a you know
Arnold Schwarzenegger involvement with
the power industry this past week he
just signed a sweetheart deal these guys
took down the state these power pirates
Enron reliance a Duke Energy Southern
Company they took down the state for
nine billion dollars that they didn't
deserve by manipulating the power
markets by cheating okay they cheated
all right instead of having to give back
the nine billion the Bush administration
first said that the public had to pay
more that they would more Schwarzenegger
just cut a deal that basically said for
you know like a dime on the dollar these
guys get to run away scot-free he did
that last week we're solving the crisis
okay so in other words he paid back very
nicely for the guys who backed him for
his race for governor and it's not being
discussed because it's very highly
technical but I'm telling people in
California right now you can just take
your nine billion dollars that are owed
to you that you could have won in court
and because of your governor its hasta
LaVista to the 9 billion Springfield is
yours a good morning good morning I've
been listening very hard to the whole
program and I just felt compelled to
have to call in good the i have several
points I'd like to just mention and then
I'll hang up and listen to your response
but I was listening to what you said
about the motor voter registration down
in Florida and that became my first
point my son was involved in that here
in New Jersey where he had changed in
July however when he went to vote when
we went there for the election in
November he wasn't there we went down to
the Election Board office we had to go
before he had to go before a judge we
were there for over six hours
this has to do with the process it's not
done correctly one last comment from our
guest you got it and by the way you
deserve a medal for going down and
fighting for that six hours if everyone
did that they wouldn't be able to take
away your democracy you got it right no
one's going to fix your democracy for
you whether you have paper trails on
computers or or there's some fancy can
fix to the computer system there's no
software patch for democracy you did it
fight for it Greg Palast thanks again
for joining us for this best hour Paul
thanks for being thank you for joining
us we'll go to the house now they're
going to take up a bill today called the
middle class alternative minimum tax
relief act loss to that